Laura's in Cincinnati hi Laura how are
you how are you better than I deserve
what's up in your world well about a
little over a month ago my husband came
to me and said I feel like told me to
sell the house
I told us the house okay and I said are
you crazy
um but we are god-fearing people so I
said okay um hear what you have to say a
little bit of backstory about seven
years ago we'd built our first home and
moved it for about five years and we
sold it unexpectedly on Facebook
actually and made a really really strong
profit took that money and put it on our
current home which we also built a year
ago no there goes the shock when my
husband said let's sell our house that
we just stole a year ago so the reason
for the potential sell the house is
because we have a hundred thousand
dollars in student loans what do you owe
on your home we owe on the home 270
what's it worth well you took my
husband's word honestly and truly and we
put it on the market and so a realtor we
have it listed for 369 nine okay so you
got about a hundred and equity minus
expenses and that would pay off your
student loan debt how much other debt do
you have we have a car that's twelve and
we have a lovely your favorite Elise
that I looked into getting out of but it
wouldn't it wouldn't benefit like we
wouldn't be of advantage to get out of
it unfortunately because we just had it
opened up in August yeah no it probably
is to your advantage of it's brand-new I
think someone at the car dealership was
giving you advice here
and so how much is your fleece payment
423 a month at your car okay and what is
your house and what other debts have you
got that's it
and what's your household income ranges
my husband I both are on variable income
and it ranges from one 115 to 120 a year
okay all right okay
well the only time I tell someone to
sell a house I'm not God
okay but the only time I tell someone to
sell a house is if a they don't like the
house and they're ready to move or B
they're in so deep on the house that
they can't breathe
and they're gonna be you know a decade
at getting out of debt because their
house poor okay and your house payment
is not more than 1/4 of your take-home
pay you have a reasonable house payment
here okay so then it comes down to this
when someone plays that God said card
that's the trump card on the top of the
deck that wins every hand okay that's
the that's the trump card if it is God
and then that's what we have to
ascertain if if I'm the one saying God
said or I'm the one hearing God said
that's going to affect my life you or
your husband's position so Sharon and I
we're a little careful about that we
usually say I think I hear God saying
because I've been walking with God a
long time and there's times I can't tell
the difference in last night's pizza and
the Holy Spirit okay so you know it's
just it's not not the people that hear
perfectly from God
scare me because I don't but I hear from
him he talks to me I mean I'm his kid
but sometimes it's last night's pizza
and sometimes it's him I can always tell
when I look back I can't always tell
looking forward I have learned a couple
of things to look for one is if my wife
and I can be in agreement that we both
are sensing that then we're pretty sure
that's going to be God because proverbs
31 says who can find a virtuous wife for
her worth as far above
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her and he will have no lack of gain so
your spouse speaking into the situation
is one way to help determine if you're
really hearing from God okay
the second thing I look for is I look
for a tremendous peace the peace that
passes understanding correct in our
prayer for the last month you know let
us follow peace yeah and then you've got
to ask yourself are you little Direction
you know if I'm in your shoes I'm asking
myself if Sharon were in this
conversation she would tell you that
what she's asking for is not direction
from her husband but direction from God
to help determine is this really him
because if it's really him the house
needs to be sold and I don't think you
question that not sure don't I don't see
that this house needs to be so looking
at these numbers right but I think if it
I think it would be okay to sell it and
I would never tell you to keep it if we
were all 100 percent sure God told you
to sell it and so if your husband heard
clearly then sell the house and you got
it on the market and you can put that
out as a fleece and say God if that's
really you then sell it if it's not you
then keep people away you know and and
but if it does not sell you have to get
rid of your car and you guys are going
to be on beans and rice rice and beans
and no vacations are no eating out
because you have a student loan mess on
your hands if it does sell if it does
sell you need to rent something cheap
until you get this debt mess cleaned up
because you make too much money to be
this broke you're broke and so I get the
pressure but sometimes people not
counting God speaks but sometimes people
want to sell their house because it's a
quick fix it's not going to be a quick
fix for you but it is going to be a fix
your car needs to be sold either way and
get you a cheaper car to drive around
until we get through this mess and then
when the house sells we can knock out
the other car and there's a bunch of the
student loan then finish off the student
loan debt and then save up for a down
payment to build you another one because
you guys are pretty good at building
houses and making money on
[Applause]
yeah well we said we would never vote
again oh okay well maybe not then but
anyway you save up and buy something
then after after you get the other side
of the debt and have your emergency fund
in place but look for a sense of peace
between the two of you are the
circumstances pointing to this that
one's on the bubble here is the is the
idea scriptural yam being debt-free
scriptural so it's okay but doesn't
require that you sell this house right
now I can't find that in Scripture but
but so I can't find it in the
circumstances I can't find it in
Scripture so the last thing I can look
to the last two things I could look to
is agreement between the husband and
wife and a sense of peace that passes
understanding that both of you have that
this is the right direction if you get
those two things then there is God I'm
good with it sell it get rid of it and
but but if you're if you really go I
don't think so I think you're just
scared about the debt honey then that's
a valid thing to question and that's not
questioning is holiness because if
you're really holy you can admit that
maybe you didn't hear or maybe you did
hear you know if you can't if you say a
hundred percent all the time I hear from
God and you don't by definition you are
not holy you're arrogant so and I don't
think your husband said that I think
he's just saying I feeling the pressure
of this and I was praying about it and I
think God's saying move the house along
and I I'm not doubting that I think that
might have happened but I don't see
anything here that's screaming one way
or the other so it's an interesting
discussion and a good discussion for
those of us that are people of faith now
some of you listening out there going
what is all that stuff because you're
not a part you know you're not a faith
person you're not a personal walking in
faith so those of us that are people of
faith you know Christians we look at
things differently and we actually are
trying to figure out what God wants us
to do and try to do that and sometimes
it's just not clear it's just hard to
figure out so but it's a good discussion
and a good question I've been absolutely
no help to you except to say be in unity
with your husband and that's not the you
cave or he caves
that's actual talking it through
intellectual emotional spiritual
relational unity but both of you are
engaged and looking for that sense of
peace that passes understanding since
there's nothing here that the scripture
indicates a hundred percent on or the
circumstances indicate a hundred percent
off it's okay to do it either way but if
we're sure God said then whatever God
said we do this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]